- I'm sure you noticed
conspicuously absent any steel.
That's because in the
first round of competition
we're giving you this.
A huge pile of 5160 spring
steel that you gotta figure
out how to forge
into a signature
blade in your signature style.
The length of your blades must
be between 10 and 13 inches.
The overall length
of your weapon
must not exceed 22 inches.
You must include a through
tang in your blade's design.
You have three hours
to forge your blades.
Good luck.
Your 10 minute design
window starts--
now.
I'm going to make
a recurve camp knife.
I know they can stab with
the drop point on them.
I want something with nice
curves that's good for slicing
and something that
I know will satisfy
the obstacles that they're
going to be put through.
Bladesmiths, your 10 minute
design window has closed.
Your three hour
forge time starts--
now.
I'm going to give
canister Damascus a shot.
But I've never done one before,
so it's a little intimidating.
Ooh!
When I think
these guys are going
for is if they stretch
out the springs it's
easier to get powder around--
Powder all the way
around that material.
If I don't put space
between each coil,
then I could end up with
delamination or cold shut.
I've never welded
before, so this is fun.
OK, so we have a smith here
that does not know how to weld.
- Come on, Andrew.
- Uh-oh.
Yeah, turn it on first.
[laughing]
Turning it on helps.
Let's see if he
gets the hang of it.
[bleep]
I mean, it's-- shoot.
I can't see through the visor.
And I'm trying to hook
the welder up to the steel
and then quickly
pull down my mask,
'cause I can't see anything.
Mother-- It's ugly.
[bleep]
Just dumped his
canister and spilled
about half his powder out.
- Ah jeez.
Oh man.
I'm pretty bummed.
But there's no way this
is going to happen.
I'm not going to
even waste time to do
something that I don't know.
I gotta do a 180 and try to make
up for all this lost time now.
I don't have time for
any more mess ups.
I've already messed up once.
Plan B is to get these
coil springs welded up.
And I'm going to get
a piece of mild steel,
wrap it around that, weld it
together for some [inaudible]..
He's got one long wire,
but so little metal.
I've got my springs
welded up, so now I
start getting my mild steel
into a sandwich shape.
I need to get it nice
and tight to where
it's not going to fall out
when I go to set my first weld.
[bleep]
Andrew's moving some steel.
The problem with
Andrew moving some steel
is he doesn't have
enough steel to even
create an edge for that thing.
I know what I'm
going to end up with,
and it's not going to
be my style or pretty,
but I just want to get a
knife done at this point.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, shut down your
machines and drop your tools!
This forging round is over.
[applause]
I hope the judges
can appreciate
that I did everything
the old-fashioned way.
I don't really
appreciate welding.
I like to do rivets.
I think welds are kind of ugly.
For the most part,
[bleep] welder.
Bladesmiths, this
was a very difficult
round one, really
challenging your problem
solving capabilities.
Now it's time for
the judges to take
a closer look at your work.
Mike, you're up.
One thing that I
like about this blade
is it's designed
for a stabbing test.
So you have that spear-like
shape over there.
I like that you have
a false edge on one
side that'll support the stab.
Andrew, you know what to do.
I'm gonna be
totally honest, MIG
welding is about the easiest
welding there is out there.
I really would
have liked to have
seen you maybe spend about 10
minutes and just figure it out.
That could definitely help
you beef this blade up, OK.
This is very lean.
Bill, you're up.
You got wires
that are sticking
up on the ends that are loose.
I can wiggle the
wires inside the taco,
so it's definitely
not welded up 100%.
[clattering]
Especially that piece.
Bill, your blade
did not make the cut.
Jay will explain.
Bill, we all really
appreciate the work
you put into that challenge,
but not having your high carbon
steel forge welded together,
it's the least developed blade
we have presented to us today.
So that's why we're
going to let you go.